لطالما كانت هناك هذه الشائعات التي
تعتزم روسيا الانسحاب من محطة الفضاء الدولية ،
فماذا سيعني بالنسبة لنا
العلاقات الفضائية الروسية إذا انسحبت روسيا ،
فلن يكون الأمر جيدًا
إذا بدأت روسيا بالاعتماد فقط على الصين ،
فأنا أتوقع أن يكون لدينا جديد تمامًا
السباق
إلى القمر مع الصين وروسيا
ضد الولايات المتحدة ، لكنني لا أتوقع
أنك تعرف كل سنوات التعاون منذ عام 1975 ،
يمكن لسياساتك أن
تقفز على الأرض بينما
أنت تتعاون بين
بلديكما لعقود من الزمان وما
يزيد عن 45 عامًا الآن.  سنوات في
الفضاء وأريد أن يستمر هذا التعاون ،
تتحدث عن
سباق فضاء آخر ، هل تعتقد أن هذا في
مستقبلنا ،
آمل ألا يحدث ذلك ، لكن أه من الواضح
أن الصين تطور القدرة
على أن تكون متطورة للغاية في الفضاء ،
فهم هذه الدولة الثانية فقط
التي
هبطت على سطح المريخ بنجاح
وقد فعلوا ذلك مؤخرًا الآن
تقول الصين
إنها ستذهب إلى القمر
ليس فقط مع البشر ولكنهم
يرسلون ثلاث
مركبات هبوط إلى  القطب الجنوبي
للقمر حيث توجد وفرة من
الماء وبالطبع علينا القلق
على الرغم من أننا سنصل بالفعل إلى
هناك أولاً ، فهم سيصلون إلى هناك
باستخدام
عدد لا يحصى من المركبات الفضائية ، وعلينا أن ننتبه
إلى أن شخصًا ما
لا يستطيع  القمر وفجأة قل أن
هذه هي أرضي ، فأنت تبقى بعيدًا ،
وهذا ليس هو الفضاء ما هي
بعض أكبر التحديات للحفاظ على
الفضاء
كأرض محايدة حتى عندما
كان لا يزال الاتحاد السوفياتي الذي كنا
نتعاون معه ، قمنا ببناء
محطة الفضاء الدولية معًا.
لدينا طاقم روسي
وطاقم أمريكي على متن
محطة الفضاء الدولية ، لا أريد
أن يتوقف هذا التعاون ، هناك حديث
قادم من روسيا والصين عن
أنهم سيعقدون صفقة معًا للذهاب
إلى القمر يمكنني أن أقول  أنت مهما كانت
السياسة
حيث لدينا علاقة متوترة للغاية
مع روسيا في الوقت الحالي على مستوى بوتين ،
لكن يمكنني أن أخبرك للعمال العاملين في الفضاء
الذين
يريدون الاستمرار في العمل معهم
برنامج الفضاء ريكى